a great day of fun had on the golf  course will make a world of difference  for families with children who have rare  diseases  every single penny that we raised for  this stays in las vegas  almost 130 golfers hit the greens at the  painted desert golf club recently for  the second annual tee up for rare golf  tournament all proceeds benefit the  little miss hannah foundation and the  turnout was incredible the community  helped raise more than 30 thousand  dollars for the foundation  that thirty thousand dollars will fund  anywhere from forty to fifty pieces of  medical and therapy equipment which is  the main focus of our foundation  and we could not be more proud of that  hearing from the executive director  jenny kershal there those pieces of  medical and therapy equipment they're  typically not covered by medical  insurance families in southern nevada  will receive the items over the next few  months